today all instinctive football a fun
show for everybody we got Zach Moss a
punishing running back from Utah and
Connor and I are gonna do something
different today we're gonna give you a
mock draft but not what we're hearing
what we would do as the general manager
of each team it's gonna be a ton of fun
I can't wait and it was nice having a
little break on Monday not gonna lie I
know rare a rare break for us but
surprisingly Matt of course we take a
day off and a lot seems to go on around
the NFL so let's just start with the
biggest thing that kind of rocked the
draft world over these last couple days
there was a report that the Dolphins are
not as high on tua as a lot of people
believe and that they've actually been
doing a lot of work on Justin Herbert I
think if you listen to this show that
wouldn't surprise you because we've been
talking about the Dolphins and Herbert
not just this year but in the previous
draft class when we thought Herbert was
going to declare so Matt when this
dropped what was your take on the entire
situation so honestly my first thought
was this is a little early for this news
to come out and I think I agree anytime
a rumor comes out or all I said anytime
a rumor is told to me I try to look at
it from both sides who benefits from
this news coming out so I could see the
Dolphins honestly liking Justin Herbert
like you said Connor I've been saying
this for like two years that they've
done a ton of work on him that would not
be a surprise now the Dolphins also
stand to gain by coming out now and
saying we don't think two is that good
you do a couple things there you
potentially drive down his market by
saying have we sit at five we don't
think two is that good
that could cause doubt for some other
GM's it could drop his stock if you're
the Dolphins and you like to ax that's
what you're going to say you're gonna
come out before the combine and be like
yeah we don't even we don't think he's
that good we're not gonna trade up for
him we don't think he's that good and
what you do there is we all assume the
Lions that three are trying to trade out
of that spot the best way to decrease
the value of that trade is to say
players not that good we saw this as
funny the 2017 draft we've been talking
about it a lot because I'm a Holmes
Watson it's funny to go back now and
look at some of the things that like
Brett Veatch and Andy Reid and John
Dorsey were saying about my homes like
will price right up for a linebacker you
know like I you know what
you know these quarterbacks aren't that
good and obviously they wanted a
quarterback they were trying to drive
down the market of those guys so I think
with the Dolphins I know the reporter
armando Segura is highly respected he's
a very good reporter but I do think
teams are wise about how to you know
inflate or deflate the value of a player
this is one way to do it and I'll tell
you something I was driving this morning
had to take my my son to school and
that's when I do a lot of my phone calls
and on the way home of us I talked to a
player personnel guy they think three
quarterbacks are gonna go in the top
five when it's all said and done with
trade so even if Miami doesn't like to a
someone will Detroit could draft him at
two so or excuse me at three so there's
enough like out there for two it unless
the medicals are just completely bombed
when we get to the combine which is
something we talked about on the Friday
show then then it he could fall but I
think the Dolphins being pretty smart
here and I think Armando has been there
long enough that he probably heard what
we were hearing during the 2018 season
that Chris career who is still there and
is the GM of the team let's be real this
was a team that they were all over
Justin Herbert during that season so
maybe the interest to land him never
went away
we just got mixed up in the fact that to
uh appeared on the map here for them and
they might have liked him as well so I'm
with you Matt there's a lot of different
directions this thing can go the problem
is if the Dolphins want to kind of play
that game and really do like to uh it
might not matter in the end because I
simply think there's gonna be a lot of
teams behind them that will gladly trade
up for tua and they won't play this game
so you can do it when teams are more
skeptical a lot of teams were skeptical
on mahomes a lot of teams were skeptical
on deshaun Watson I think barring health
concerns which are significant I don't
think teams are skeptical on to a from a
traits perspective as a pro prospect
yeah I agree
it injuries the biggest thing and it is
it is big so that that will be out there
one team that will be in trade talks a
lot the Detroit Lions at number three
overall and came over to the weekend
they are at least talking about trading
Darius Leigh who I think he's always
been one of the more underrated corners
and the
fell in a really really good win
especially if you're in a defense that
wants to play man coverage
Darius lay is gonna be very good for you
he's under contract for one more year at
ten million dollars he's 29 years old
just turned 29 January 1st actually so I
think if you look at teams we've talked
a lot about mellows team the Chiefs my
team the Niners he'll your team the Jets
a lot of teams out there they haven't
need four corners and Darius slay who
could probably be had for a day to pick
that's a really good return on
investment for a short window so these
teams that are picking late in the round
especially like late round two early
round three I think it's I would be
pretty interested in making a call and
Darius slay who again it's probably for
one year it's a short-term window but
like we saw I mean we saw the Niners
trade for Emmanuel Sanders who's now a
free agent
we saw D Ford probably gonna be cut
after this year we've seen the Rams do
this a lot trading for Dante Fowler who
was then a free agent they traded for
Sammy Watkins who was a free agent so
we've seen teams do this a lot in the
past Adam Schefter said there's multiple
teams and any team that trades first leg
would likely have to give him a new deal
yeah the good thing about slay he's a
really good corner he's a good player at
a premium position the bad thing about
slay is that he's now 29 years old we've
seen what happens to corners when they
get to that thirty year kind of gap and
I know Richard Sherman's a little
different but Xavier Rhodes ain't even
there yet and he can't run anymore Revis
absolutely fell off a cliff so a lot of
guys start to decline that corner when
they get to 30 and the other thing is
Matt you probably got to pay the guy 15
million dollars a year we're looking at
a free agency period where James
Bradbury
is probably gonna get 12 to 14 million
dollars a year so what does that make
Darius slay worth that's the issue with
all this so I think the teams that'll be
interested are teams that are ready to
win but also have left themselves with a
lot of cat flexibility where you can go
get a premium player for a second I
think a third-round picks pretty light
but once again the contract expectations
that come with acquiring him definitely
the value for the liens and once again
Matt are we gonna have a conversation
about this Lions team running out all
their good players because at some point
you can only do this for so long before
you're sitting there you have no talent
and I don't really know you know what
Matt Patricia has done to warrant these
kind of moves it goes back to what I say
about my team all the time with Adam
GaSe running out talented players
it feels very similar with Matt
Patricius so far it really does I mean
the quandary Dix trade is just it's when
I go back to we still can't figure it
out it's amazing that they've held on to
Kenny Galilei who's a really good player
and probably has exceptional value and
we've talked before about Matt Stafford
they really just can't trade him right
now because the contract another player
who's gonna be on the move at the corner
position and I think teams that don't
get slay will probably be calling Chris
Harris Jr who has said over the weekend
that moving on from the Broncos seems
like the right direction that could
obviously change once contracts talks
start really in about two weeks of the
combine it's when all that's gonna
happen I think for Chris Harris who
again a guy who's a little bit older but
has been so good for Denver and he's
done a lot of different things he's
played slot where I remember Pro
Football Focus first starting and Chris
Harris was always like the top-ranked
coroner cuz how good he was in a slot he
will turn 31 years old in June so a
little bit old but the way he plays I
feel like we haven't seen like the
athleticism drop off from him and he's
so good with technique a lot like you're
gonna mark where he can play a little
bit longer because it's not just pure
speed he played football at K you
he's from Tulsa Oklahoma and I know that
location doesn't always matter but two
teams that are in that region the Dallas
Cowboys the Kansas City Chiefs could
both use a guy like this immediately
now with the Chiefs monies obviously
gonna be an issue he's not gonna get 15
million dollars a year most likely from
Kansas City but I would think that he's
got to look at those teams men where
instead of having to stop the homes
twice a year you're on his team and if
you go to Dallas where they're gonna
lose Byron Jones to free agency you got
to feel like that you got a pretty good
shot to win a Super Bowl within the next
couple years which yeah we've had Chris
on this podcast for he's an amazing guy
that's really the only thing missing
from him
you know here obviously got one with
with Peyton came through there but what
if he could get another one at the end
here I think we're talking about such a
great run for a guy who was an undrafted
free agent out of Kansas an unbelievable
career so far for Chris Harris jr. one
of the more you know one of the most
impressive undrafted careers that we
have seen and like you said we've had
him on this show he was one of my
favorite guests just talking to him you
understand why he's had so much success
for such a long time wherever he goes
and I do think you bring up a good point
now the Cowboys at face value have a ton
of cap space how much cap space are they
gonna have after they sign their
franchise quarterback they're number one
wide receiver and if they do go after a
corner they should retain their own guy
and Byron Jones who's younger and has
had so much success there so for Chris
Harris jr. I'm fascinated to see which
route he goes Matt that's what it comes
down to for me does he go the route
where he says you know what I'll take a
lower than market value deal to go chase
another super bill and finish my career
on a higher note with maybe a more
prestigious franchise or do I want to
cash out one more time so and when you
look at what Chris Harris jr. has done
let's not forget Matt he took an
extremely team friendly deal in Denver
rather than hitting the open market on
free agency because he didn't want to
risk that injury factor again that
contract extension really had him at cap
numbers between nine and ten million
that's not a lot of money for a corner
the caliber of Chris Harris jr. right
now he can one years old going into a
season where he'll be 31 he can exceed
that number there are teams out there
that'll give him 12 million dollars a
year now the guarantees will be upfront
in the first two years of the deal but
the bottom line is he does have an
opportunity if he wants you to get a big
payday one more time yeah it's gonna be
I think Chris is gonna be smart about
this he's gonna go somewhere where he
can be an immediate fit obviously you
know they're gonna he's gonna ask the
questions hey what type of defense you
were running because maybe he wasn't a
great fit with what Vic Fangio brought
in there I think we could even see him
get back to the slot and be really
impactful we were gonna talk about
Philip Rivers but we've kind of
exhausted that I do want to say our guy
Tony Jefferson got cut over the weekend
maybe this might've been a Friday news
dump the Ravens cut Tony Jefferson after
they signed Chuck Clark to an extension
Tony uh it was injured which is the
downside of this you know we talked
Kenny Vaccaro about this a lot the
safety market that one year was down
wishing the best for our guy he's been a
great interview on here we love
interacting with him so I think we will
be watching my team the Niners
hopefully have some interest in Tony
Jefferson when it's all said and done he
almost signed with your Jets back in the
day when he was a free agent you guys
don't need his safety
anymore but I think the market for
Tony's gonna be good
yeah I'll say this Tony's gonna be just
fine after coming off a really really
nice stint with the Baltimore Ravens and
you know we're wishing him luck not only
finding his new team but finishing up
his rehab and getting ready for the
season I wouldn't be surprised Matt if
he's on the comeback player of the year
radar for us before the season kicks off
yeah I think so let's take a break we
come back we're gonna give you a little
mock draft Wednesday and they're closing
the show today with our guys Zach Moss
we told you guys we were doing something
different this week with the mock drafts
and we are this is what we would do as
the general manager of each team Connors
taking the odds I'm taking evens and you
are up number one the Cincinnati Bengals
I imagine it's the easiest pick you've
probably ever made in a mock draft it's
easy for me sitting here picking for the
Bengals I don't know if it's easy for
the guy I'm calling up to the stage I'm
taking Joe borough first overall will he
listen to the stage I I know and I
understand if you're a Bengals fan and
this seems like a sensitive subject I
totally understand and I'm not ringing
the panic alarm yet but I will say Joe
burrow has now had countless
opportunities in interviews that just
give a simple if the bengals draft me i
would love to go play there and he has
past that opportunity every time and if
he doesn't want to do that that's fun he
doesn't have to say that leave all
options on the table but I'm just saying
Matt and I click on the links I don't
just read the headlines of the snippets
of the quote because I don't want Joe to
ever be misquoted
it's just getting
little a little interesting it is and
our guy Melo keeps saying the heap like
he thinks there's something to this
you know because and that's what he said
on the Friday show like hey he could
just come out and say I'm okay they drop
me I'm fine with it
so this morning I read where Joe said
they have the first pick but I have all
the leverage and that they had not had a
conversation yet about if he wanted to
go there that basically you got two
months so Joe is the easy picker number
one overall he's the best quarterback in
the draft he's the number two player on
my board I think anyone who listens to
this knows Big Joe borough fan right
here I have no idea where he is at and I
wrote my scouting notebook that came out
Friday morning that they want him
they have signaled that they want him
but I think it's just a matter of is he
going to go when it's time and I like
you said we understand that Bengals fans
don't want to hear this and we're not
trying to pile on you guys but there's
something to this that he hasn't just
come out and said yeah I want to be
there if they draft me it'll be an honor
to go back to my home state to represent
southeast Ohio and be a Cincinnati
Bengal he hasn't said that and I think
that is interesting now a number two
overall I have what is probably the
second easiest pick ever because the
Washington Redskins should draft chase
young if I were GM they would draft
chaser unless Joe burrows on the board
in which case I would draft geo borough
and trade Dwayne Haskins immediately but
if if Joe's gone number one chase young
is again I think we've over thought this
player he is rare in terms of his get
off his quickness he's understanding of
how to use his body in his speed I saw a
quote now I wish I could remember who
said it somebody said that he had like
slowed down after his suspension and
that is ridiculous nonsensical if you
actually watched him play he was being
constantly doubled and tripled from the
moment he came back against Penn State
into Ohio State season ended so I'm a
huge chase young fan I don't know yet
where everyone always wants to know
where's he gonna rank for you all time
as a pass rusher I don't know yet I
think he's a lot like Miles Garrett for
me I don't
I don't think that would be higher than
Nick Bose oh but he's way way up there
in the Redskins to be really fortunate
to have him yeah I'm with you on that
one
it's just it's kind of simple there now
I'll say this Matt you know kind of
transitioning to the next pic here Jeff
Okuda is extremely extremely impressive
and I think that getting the pass rusher
is just a little bit more important than
the premium corner I agree but I will
say just on greats not positional but or
positional value Okuda is just really
close to chase young that's how good he
is it's not a knock on chase young a
coot is just phenomenal and that's why
at number three I haven't gone to the
Lions now if we're and we're gonna do
trades once we get to that the Lions
probably should trade this pick you just
you need the draft capital you're
rebuilding a lot of teams that are up
here that aren't looking for a
quarterback should look to trade chase
young is gone somebody will want to come
up whether it's for two or Justin
Herbert but if I'm not moving the pick
is very very easy if I'm the Lions Jam
and that is Jeff CUDA he could do
everything whether it's press man
coverage whether you know I will say
he's better in man coverage than zone
but I truly believe what his traits the
length the speed the clicking clothes
the ability to play the ball in the air
a CUDA can really flourish in any kind
of scheme and be your number one corner
and that is a huge need for them
especially if they tried slants it yes
so this if you don't he's you still need
it a corner exactly
so yeah big need for them I think that
makes the most sense
number four the New York Giants we have
had a lot of conversations about where
this could go where it should go in my
opinion Jedrek wills the left right
tackle from Alabama I would plug him at
a left tackle figure out whatever you
want to do in a solder whether it's move
him the right tackle
cut him trade him get him out of there
Jedrek wills to me is the top tackle in
this class and I I tweeted about this a
little bit Tuesday morning it's
surprising to me when you talk to folks
in the NFL how different they are all in
the offensive tackles I think it's wills
and then you could maybe have a
conversation but I think he is head and
shoulders the best tackle in this draft
I know that drafting a left tackle or an
offensive lineman
general is not the sexiest pic even guys
like Laremy Tunsil and Ronnie Stanley
who have become all pro players you can
look back at those drafts and no one
talks about how good of a pic Ronnie
Stanley was for Baltimore because we
talked about my Holmes and Watson and
joy Bosa those are really good
foundational type pics and when you have
a quarterback that you like and you have
a great running back you have some
receivers for me this is the way to go
other than chase young or Jeff Okuda I
think Jedrek wills has to be the pick
for the Giants
yeah once again I'm not gonna disagree
with you I know some Giants fans will
but I would try to not only this is a
two for one win here Matt you're
protecting Daniel Jones who every time
he got hit last year coughed up the
football right you're opening up running
lanes for a running back you used a
number two overall pick on number two
overall like I don't want a thousand
yards from say qualm barkley I want 16
to 1,700 rushing yards and I look at
wills at once again I'm with you he's in
his own tier and I love Tristan Dwarfs I
like what Andrew Thomas and McKay Becton
can do to an offensive line in terms of
upgrading those units and pass pro in
the run game but wills is in his own
tier their number 5 the Miami Dolphins -
it falls right into their lap we're
gonna say every single time it's it's
barring medicals and if you believe - it
can stay healthy I think when he was
healthy - it was the most talented
quarterback in this class I love the fit
in Miami I really like that listen if
you don't want to rush him back you
don't have to you got the fits magic
they're still one more year under
contract he's ready to come in and play
another year there in Miami so this is
an easy no-brainer at number five it's
tua it is if he's healthy he should go
earlier than this just with traits like
you said obviously number six the Los
Angeles chargers in the mock drafts that
we do based on what we hear we almost
always have a quarterback go here
whether it was to a falling or Justin
Herbert rising I'm not going that
direction if I'm the LA Chargers I find
a way to get Cam Newton and I roll out
there with Cam and tire out in East and
stick and say this is good enough for
right now you don't have to trade number
68 Cam Newton by the way so with the
number six pick I'm gonna look at Kansas
City San Francisco Philadelphia some of
great defenses that we saw late this
year especially and focus on the d-line
you already have nick Bosa or joey boss
excuse me whose amazing you already have
melvin ingram well you really don't have
as someone in the middle of this defense
and I know they've spit pics trying to
make this happen I would draft Derrick
Brown and I that's not like the most oh
my god this is a great pic it's gonna be
plug him in right away I know they drive
to Jerry Tillery last year in the first
round but if you could put Derrick
Bryant he could play knows he could play
shade he can kick inside as a three
technique so between Justin Jones and
Jerry Tillery those are solid players
Derrick brown is one of the four or five
best players in this draft class and I
think in most drafts he would have been
the top d tackle available so again not
the sexiest pick but I don't value a
left tackle here so not gonna reach on
one of those and I think Derrick Brown
is just so good he and Isiah Simmons are
the two guys where I almost feel like
they're just so talented you kind of
forget team needs and just go this is
the best player on the board you're this
good we will find a spot for you if you
get a boast Derrick brown and Melvin
Ingram as your core pass-rush group I
mean that's that's pretty [ __ ] tough
yeah I can't hate on that at all I mean
this is someone who was drawing double
teams against the best offenses in the
country in the SEC that's how good
Derrick Brown was you go back to the LSU
tape they were looking to double-team
this guy to take him out upfront he's a
game changer and I'll say this
I love Javon Kinlaw and I love Derrick
brown and I do think they're close to
each other
I think Brown is technically a little
further ahead than Kinlaw he just does
the little things right you can often
see it so he's somebody that can wreck
the game both as a pass rusher and as a
run defender and like you said all that
attention he draws up front number seven
the Carolina Panthers not gonna panic
and take a quarterback here but we'll
take a quarterbacks best friend and that
is my number two offensive lineman in
this draft I believe you agree with that
Matt interesting worse from Iowa I think
works can play right tackle I think he
could be a very good guard what he does
the second level of the football field
can change run games and when he gets
his hands on you it's
it's as simple as that and the track
record of Iowa offensive lineman versus
next in line he's got that kind of not
only mental makeup but physical makeup
so for the Panthers building a
powerhouse unit in the trenches is
something that Matt rule is definitely
gonna want early on before their next
quarterback even gets there and that's
what I would do - I love like you said I
love works I talk to a lot of people to
say hey I think he's a guard I think
he's a tackle and I think it's a really
good one I think he probably an all-pro
guard number eight the Arizona Cardinals
we saw them extend left tackle GJ
Humphries a three-year deal over the
weekend that to me signifies they don't
feel like they have to go tackle and
number eight overall I think what they
should do Larry if it shows back for one
year Gerry Judy's available here and we
talked about this with Chase young and
Jeff a CUDA like we are overthinking
these players because they've been good
for two years you're probably tired of
hearing us talk about them I would run
to the frickin podium and draft Jerry
Judy here if you have your left tackle
back Kyler Marie is only going to get
better in this offense I believe as he
and Kliff Kingsbury get more on the same
page as cliff dials up and changes
things to work better at the NFL level
give him a dynamic player I know we
talked about christian kirk christiansen
done anything i think you have a future
need at number one receiver get Jerry
Judy in this offense his speed his burst
his body control the way he comes out of
routes would be so perfect for Cliff
Kingsbury's offense I think you have to
take Judy if he's there
once again that's what I would have done
there a I would have taken Judy I just
think he can be a twelve hundred yard
player in Cliff's offense with Kyler
maybe even more but from day one who
come in and be a super productive number
one wide receiver I do know a lot of
people and I've been guilty of this as
well with Arizona have you know drawn
the CD lamb ties there with him and
Kyler but I think in terms of what Judy
can do and how high his floor is that
would be the pick at eight number nine
the Jaguars this is where I'm gonna go
with Isaiah Simmons and Matt this is
your same argument you had with Derek
Brown at six
you kind of overthink it a little bit at
times you start getting a little you
know particular with team needs and
premium positions and all of that stuff
and then
over look really really good football
players and that's my situation here at
9:00 with Jacksonville Isiah Simmons is
somebody that can play linebacker for
them he can blitz he can cover he's a do
it all Swiss Army knife on the defense
that can take this unit to the next
level and listen they've lost a really
key player there and Jalen Ramsey
we don't know what's gonna happen up
front with their pass rusher and Yannick
and gawk way so it's Simmons this is a
superstar talent plugs right in the
middle of the Jacksonville front it
makes so much sense
tell them Smith we don't think he's ever
coming back Isiah Simmons I think could
be an upgrade at that spot it puts you
back in a position where Myles jack can
do what he does best
I love that for Jacksonville number 10
the Cleveland Browns who knows what this
team's gonna do I think predicting the
Browns will be very difficult what they
should do though draft an offensive
tackle to protect Baker Mayfield to
allow this downfield passing game to
flourish because it could not with the
line they had last year
Kevin Stefanski we saw at a Minnesota he
can get by without a great offensive
line but this one is really really bad
at tackle Makai Becton say what you will
about his ranking I have him in the 20s
we know tackles tend to rise up the
board I think Becton is gonna dominate
the combine and we're all gonna see why
Daniel Jeremiah put him at number four
overall in that senior ball mock draft
the kind of rock to the world I don't
love Becton I don't love beckons tape
let me say that I think his potential is
astronomically good and he's working
with the right guy in Duke Mantee
whether to fix the flaws in his game so
when I evaluate Becton that's the the
trouble for me
what I saw a Louisville versus what I
think he can be guys like that and we've
said this before that's where you're
boom or bust come into play because it's
not what you are it's what you could be
I think Beck Deniz he's an exceptional
ball of clay they could be dialed into a
great left tackle but there is a little
bit of risk here
I think the Browns can take that risk
because this offense is really a left
tackle away from being very explosive
Matt do you think with Becton people on
Twitter are falling a little bit for the
the knock out highlights like a great
fighter and like recepies Kimbo Slice
but Kimbo
slice was the king of you post a 12
second clip and you go wow that's the
greatest knockout I've ever seen yeah
and then you put him in the cage and he
couldn't fight anyone it felt like at
times and you know no disrespect to
Kimbo but and I'm not saying Becton is
gonna fail in the NFL I'm just saying
he's being developed right now into a
rounded out player and the knockout
shots are incredible and I do think he's
much more athletic than I ever expected
for his size as a pass protector minimal
feat for someone that's 6 7 365 but
don't you feel like sometimes we fall
for the a couple of highlights and you
go man he probably does that every play
and I think we're just not there yet
it's funny Melo and I were having this
exact conversation Sunday night and I
said you know there are times he reminds
me of Greg Robinson who coming out had
the same deal he had so many knockout
shots playing left tackle we were like
this is the future of offensive tackle
play and we kind of forgot that he
didn't do the little things well I like
the Becton is working to get that fixed
but you are absolutely right it is like
it's like watching a guy be a great
dunker and then it's like but can you
actually play basketball he was Becton
the Knockouts are there the pancakes are
amazing if he gets his hands on you days
over I want to see that the clips where
he doesn't get hands on people cuz there
are there quite a few of those and again
not to knock a guy it might sound like
we're being overly harsh on Becton just
trying to explain the discrepancy
between where he is you know even here I
took him at number 10 overall he's
ranked at like 23 for me it's a pretty
big discrepancy the potential is just
enormous I was just gonna say it's it's
no disrespect you took him in the top 10
so Becton is an extremely valued player
and I think Duke is gonna do great work
getting him ready not only for the
combine but beyond that but once again I
think he's just making the audience
aware that are you getting a franchise
tackle from day one maybe not yet it's
gonna take a little bit of time but the
ceiling is so high with him number 11
the New York Jets they're another team
that needs offensive line Jerry judy is
off the board so I can't take him I'm
going with Andrew Thomas from Georgia
here what I love about Thomas is not
only how tough he is in the run game but
I love how smart he is and it's
something the Jets really really
struggled with last year and this was
something Adam GaSe is units in Miami
struggled with for a couple years they
can't pick up a stunt to save their
lives and it puts Sam darn along the
ground time and time again and actually
think Thomas is underrated best quality
is how well he did that at Georgia for
Jake from I think his IQ and awareness
around him made up four times him
playing high or him not moving as well
as you'd like in pass fro because he
always knows where to be he has such a
good field awareness of when to run guys
out whether to drive guys back so I love
Thomas's IQ and I would gladly take him
at 11 to upgrade this Jets offensive
line whether you want to play him at
left tackle right tackle I don't think
they'll be fortunate enough to have the
luxury to ever play him a card yeah
probably not I think I feel like that's
another guy who's being overthought a
little bit because he doesn't look the
part but he played the part in the SEC
which is is pretty hard to do a lot of
people ask me and they take both of us
in this they say what happened to Andrew
Thomas what caused this fall I don't
think this is a fall at all I think this
is right where we had him preseason but
other guys it's with Becton it's a
ceiling with wills it's oh it was an
underclassmen that just really was
phenomenal this year and same could be
said with worse guys just rose ahead of
him but that doesn't really change the
kind of player he is and can be yeah big
fan of him I'm gonna take 12 the Las
Vegas Raiders the guy that I thought you
were going to take see deal am i would
be running to the frickin desk with or
swimming to the stage with a card in my
hand what if this went down cassini lamb
is what they need and I know some
Raiders fans are gonna say that but we
need we need speed you do but you also
need a possession receiver and CDs not
gonna run well but he is so physical
well he does after the catch is still
special without having elite top in
speed so CD lamb for me is such an easy
picture yeah it really is I think the
Raiders fans would absolutely love that
one in what's gonna be a really exciting
first round for them 13 sorry Colts fans
I know you're probably hoping for Jordan
love I would not make that pick I'm
gonna go Henry rogues here instead now
this could be flipped completely upside
down if what Melvin Gordon says comes
true that he thinks Phillip Rivers
ends up with the cult's and they don't
really go into this trap looking for a
quarterback because then they'd have
that per set under the cap unless they
trade them they'd have rivers on the cap
and they'd just be kicking the can down
the road at quarterback listen if you do
that you need really good players around
him and I think Henry rogue's is a
really really good player the Colts have
the capital to move up for one of the
top tackles say Anthony Costanzo does
retire then they would have to think
about that but in this draft they stayed
here and they get rugs who he changes
the game when the ball is not coming his
way the way you have to sit on your
heels is the defense with rugs out there
it's the same thing the teams have to do
when they play Tyreke Hill and the
Chiefs so I love what rugs bring soon
not only the Colts passing attack but
also their run game for our guy and
friend of the show Marlon Mac what is
your thinking here with the quarterback
are you thinking that it will be Philip
Rivers you okay with Jacoby Brissette
because I think a lot of people are
gonna want it like Justin Herbert's on
the board yeah well I would not bet the
house on Justin Herbert number one if
I'm the Colts and number two that cap
hit for chip Kobe perset is no laugher I
just want to make that clear like you're
not gonna if you take Herbert Orlov I
guess you would sit them and play per
set but I'm comfortable with going into
this year with Brissette and positioning
myself for next year's quarterback class
I just I'll say it if I'm in the GM
chair I'm being selective and in the top
15 I'm not taking Herbert or love as my
the future of the franchise I'm just not
comfortable doing it and it's it's a
personal opinion with me and maybe it's
some will say it's drafting scared but
for the Colts I like their roster a lot
I don't think Jacoby perset is as bad as
every single fan apparently thinks so
where I like him for at least one more
year and looking at next year's
quarterback class where nobody stacks
draft capital better than Chris Ballard
in my opinion and I think if they want
one of those quarterbacks next year they
can position themselves to do so that
was all those things for like I knew
your answer I just wanted know you're
glad you did because Twitter would have
been pretty ugly for me on a fine
Wednesday if I didn't explain myself I
got you back on that one so I'll take
Justin Herbert fort
because and I'm not not a huge Herbert
guy I have been really torn on Herbert
vs. love because they both have things
that I like they both have things that I
don't like and so I get torn on this I
do think Justin Herbert would be a good
fit for Bruce Arians offense the thing
is I don't think he could play right
away in this offense so there's a little
bit of like the team-building side of it
that you have to figure out I do like
Justin Herbert's arm his ability to a
vertical I want to see who he can become
away from Oregon where his receivers
weren't good it felt like he was not
really allowed to run a lot which is a
strength to his game I think Herbert
would be good for Bruce Arians and
honestly this just comes down to me
would you rather have Jameis Winston or
Justin Herbert and I would rather have
Justin Herbert the Jameis Winston so
taking a little bit of a gamble on the
the unknown here over what you already
have man I'd rather go take a nap Evan
have either of those no I like the
scheme fit a lot for Herbert I'll say
that here I really really like the
scheme fit for year if he went to the
Bucks I wouldn't be really harsh on
grading that especially since he fell
all the way to 14 in this draft but the
one thing you make a great point about
him not really having any receivers but
he did have the best offensive line in
college football so at the end of the
day it all kind of starts to balance out
a little bit
15 the Denver Broncos this is where
Javon Kinlaw falls off the board
man he is just a wrecking ball Matt you
watch him against Alabama when you can
move back Liman that play for Alabama
you can move back linemen that play in
the NFL and I think Kinlaw can do that
exactly and for the Broncos they're kind
of a team in the middle right now we
need to see more of Drew lock so feel
comfortable that he's the guy of the
future I thought he flashed really
nicely I love their receivers they're
you know love what Courtland Sutton can
do for them I think he's just been
phenomenal they have a couple running
backs there I would have liked to add to
the offensive line there's no one really
in this spot that I feel comfortable
taking so take one of the better players
if not the best player on the board here
and that's Kinlaw I love killing and he
would be such a great fit in this
defense defense I've studied back from
the Justin Smith days like if you want
to know the fit for Javon Kinlaw you
look at justice migi looking to force
Buckner what those guys have done
San Francisco Kinloss fits that
perfectly last pic before the break
another edge rusher 16 the Atlanta
Falcons
they need speed with a value character
guys if they keep this pick I think
Kayla Vaughn chase on is an easy target
for them he played in their Stadium a
couple times this year
LSU did I think chase on can be what
they really hoped Vic Beasley would
become and what he flashed being that
second year opposite tack McKinley chase
on is gonna give you a full day's work
to handle with his speed I know he needs
to round out his game a little bit more
I think he is doing that now I'm excited
to see what he looks like in a week in
Indianapolis because I'm a huge believer
in the upside of chase on I'm with you
on that I just think the traits for him
he's loaded up with traits and when you
hear all the good things about his
character it makes you believe that he
could reach his potential at the next
level and I mean I'll tell you one guy
Matt that I completely missed on and
Shea Suns not him but you talk about
someone with a lack of production but
great traits coming out of the same
program Daniil Hunter was that guy we
all missed on that one man still hurts
sorry let's take a break when we come
back we're putting Connor on the clock
with the Dallas Cowboys the Dallas
Cowboys have a lot of hard decisions to
make as those Oregon Connor Rodgers what
is the pick for Dallas at 17
man no Kinlaw no Derek brown on the
board I think the drops of the next
d-line is Ross Blacklock and I'm not
gonna go there at 17 Matt so I'm gonna
give them the best safety that is Xavier
McKinney here this is someone that could
solidify the back end of the Dallas
defense I like what he does in coverage
more than I even expected I've seen them
come down hill I've seen him really
closed so well in pursuit but I think
he's very good in coverage to at
McKinney's to do it all safety here that
would it would solve a lot of problems
for this Dallas defense especially if
they lose Byron Jones they're gonna need
more help they're on the back end that's
secondary it's kind of amazing it's just
not as good as we think it is you know
you're like could you think about Dallas
like that defense is actually pretty
good secondary maybe not so much number
18 the Miami Dolphins they got to a at
number five I'm gonna remind everybody
of that here I'm gonna go left tackle
Josh Jones this has been a popular pick
for us and it is what I would do I like
Josh Jones is up side I don't know that
he's gonna be a great day one starting
tackle in the NFL what I saw from Monday
to Saturday in Mobile Alabama at the
Senior Bowl was really impressive for me
just the the growth that he showed he's
coachable he's smart he's very athletic
so I think Josh Jones we've talked a lot
about oh like we got the top four
tackles in this class
Jones deserves round one talk and I
think he's gonna slot in here in the
teens and in the 2020 draft yeah I think
so too I don't think if fall is gonna be
very far for him 19 the Raiders are back
on the clock and they got a great player
in Sidi lamb thanks to you Matt it's
well Dover 12 overall now at 19 I'm
gonna go we do the wide receiver
linebacker 204 Oakland Vegas every
single time but I feel good about it
because every time we do it the fans
seem pretty happy and we've had our ups
and downs as Raider fans so I'd like to
stay on the good side and I'm gonna go
Patrick Queen here from LSU kenneth
maria patrick queen
take one of them at 19 i'm the flavor of
the week this time is queen i love what
he can do in coverage and I think that's
something that'll really really help the
Raiders defense his speed is just so
noticeable on the football field whether
it is against the outside run or where
there is running with tight ends and
running backs I think this is probably
the easiest pick of the second half of
round 1 is Patrick Queen to the Raiders
he fits exactly what they need 20 the
Jags now earlier you gave them Isaiah
Simmons one of the best players in the
class I'm gonna stay on the defensive
side I think we could go receiver here
we go offensive tackle but CJ Henderson
is available he is my number 11 12
number 12 overall player in this year's
class we've talked about in million
times jaylen Rams he's gone
you need a corner I love CJ Henderson 6
1 200 pounds he's all the things we
always turn no he's not a great tackler
but he is very fiscal and his coverage
he's twitchy he's instinctive I think
for some reasons corner classes kind of
being forgotten about I think because
you know it's a great receiver year
we've talked a lot about tackles and
quarterbacks
it's a really good corner class CJ
Henderson definitely and my opinion
belongs here 20 overall 21 the Eagles I
know they'd like some speed at wide
receiver I'm gonna go with T Higgins
who's not the fastest guy in this class
but you see him win over the top you see
him win at the catch point he does
really good things after the catch he's
runner baby more talent at wide receiver
for Carson Wentz Matt I mean you can't
just have Greg Ward out there every
single week I mean come on now let's be
real here I love their tight end offense
they have some really good players that
running back but they need to go to
target at wide receiver and and tease
kind of that do it all guy where we've
seen him win deep but once again we've
also seen him take over as a possession
guy and when he's on he's a touchdown
machine in the red zone I would have
drafted him here with the Buffalo Bills
pick if you had not so this is a really
good value for E Hagins to go here 22
the bills they obviously need a receiver
if t Higgins isn't available I think
they have to go speed and that's where a
guy we really wanted to see Brandon I
you could the Senior Bowl he was injured
wasn't there I think he's gonna put on a
show at the combine
and put himself into this top 25 top 30
pick range every every Scout I've talked
to says he's better than Nikhil Harry
and Nikhil went 32nd so stands to reason
he's probably gonna go higher than that
when I watch IU he reminds me of Sammy
Watkins at Clemson not so much same in
the NFL where injuries have been an
issue but just that dynamic ability
after the catch
I like IU I think especially in this
offense they need somebody who can be a
little bit of a route runner but it's
just explosive this offense is kind of
slow I think I who changes that
immediately yeah he does just get the
ball in his hands I mean every time he
has the ball in his hands he does
something crazy after the catch so for
the bills I mean we saw John Brown of a
really nice season there we saw Cole
Beasley do some nice things
Devin Singletary obviously knocks at
tight end they got some really young
players that can make things happen but
IU seems to be one of those missing
pieces that would really help there 23
the New England Patriots the Patriots
speaking like they better need a missing
piece tight end is one for New England
right now and I'm gonna go at Cole
commit from Notre Dame
I don't think he's crunk let's not get
crazy it's always tough being the guy
after the guy but with commit he is a
big body target up the seam in the red
zone I thought he blocked really really
well we talked about him with Brian
Kelly and Brian Kelly was you know
giving praise on how much value there is
to an in line
guy and NFL teams view commit as a
reliable inline guys so I think for New
England here this is kind of one of
those no-brainer match made in heaven
scenario they could probably even trade
out of this pick Matt back a little bit
and still get their guy in commit
I think so too if he's their guy that's
definitely an intriguing way to go I
would wonder with Jordan Love and Jacob
Eason on the board how much they would
consider a quarterback here everyone
tells everyone will say they love Jairus
did him wonder how much they love him I
think that would be interesting here
number 20 for the New Orleans Saints I'm
going to draft Jordan Love here part of
the mythology at Patrick mahomes was
that the Saints were going to draft him
the Chiefs had to get ahead of them and
Sean Payton has said this yeah we were
gonna draft him they have not really
taken a quarterback since then Teddy's a
free agent Drew Brees Ephrata and even
if he's back he's gonna retire very soon
taste some hills restricted free agent
for all the talk about tasting he's 30
years old he's thrown thirteen passes
the NFL's not a starting quarterback I'm
just not buying it it's not buying it if
Jordan gloves available I think this is
a great pick for them because he doesn't
have to come into play right away he can
play behind Drew Brees for a year learn
the ropes learn the system and you have
a quarterback with exceptional traits
big arm very very mobile and everyone
I've talked to has said Jordan loves a
pretty smart guy he's not gonna have the
troubles coming in and learning in
offense I think this is the better fit
for him than going somewhere like Indy
where he might have to play right away
or Tampa where he's gonna have to play
right away I think falling a little bit
in the draft would be the best thing
possible for Jordan love where he's
gonna be surrounded by a really damn
good team in a year if this is where he
ends up I'm with you this would be a
really ideal scenario for him I do think
gut feeling and that's why it happens
every time we do the mock drafts of what
we hear or think will happen versus what
we would do love will go earlier than
this but for him and the Saints that's a
pretty good match they're 25 the
Minnesota Vikings I'm taking Jeff
Gladney here he's my number two corner
in this class
I think he's got great speed he's a
little light but great speed he's feisty
in coverage he's sticky in coverage
Gladney is someone that could fit that
Minnesota defense it's over with Xavier
Rhodes and they're lucky that a player
of glad knees caliber falls all the way
to 25 in this spot
yeah Gladney again the corners are
getting forgotten in this class I don't
know
because I love Gladney and I love CJ
Anderson and and we're gonna talk about
a couple other guys this corner class is
really good we should just start that
movement like hey quarter quarter class
is good guys it's okay to be excited you
know it's funny Matt I was talking with
someone last night and I because I was
doing a podcast it was a Ravens podcast
and I brought up Gladney and they were
ally and we were at this game actually
they were like oh do you remember when
Gladney shut down Hakim Butler and I was
laughing cuz I was like yeah Matt hi and
and Melo and Dalton we were at that game
yeah and at the time we were sitting
there saying well this is everyone's
favorite wide receiver and he did
nothing and it's like oh the guy across
from him was really really good yeah it
was funny because it's like I think he
Butler slow you know it's like he can't
get away from this guy he was slow but
also Jeff Gladney was was really really
good that it I'm Nicky Butler's not that
slow I mean he didn't we've seen worse
but yeah you're right we were at that
game that the game that we really
thought David Montgomery would kind of
take over so it was Jeff Putney that was
a great day
mellow almost died that day the first
tailgate tour ever if I'm correct oh the
one after Austin yeah second one so
first okay tour I've ever been to like
three people were at that when it was a
great day number 26 the Miami Dolphins
on the board against we've gone to ax
and Josh Jones I'm gonna go running back
here I know Dolphins fans hate it I'll
get tweets about this for people would
be like why do you keep doing this Ryan
Fitzpatrick led your team in rushing
that's why I keep doing this you need a
running back there's no one on that
roster well I believe could be a
starting running back in the NFL Jodrey
swift for all the love that there is out
there for McCaffrey and Kamara and sake
wanna guys who can do it all this is
that guy he can't do it all just fall in
love with him it's okay it's okay to
like a running back especially late
first round you're getting a five to
seven years of really good running back
play and then you move on it's fine
kaylynn balázs is not the guy y'all need
to get over this belief that he's the
guy
Myles Gaskin is not the guy Jodrey Swift
solves your problem in one pick of your
13 selections one
pick your run game has changed so just
lean into a dolphin's fence yeah kaylynn
balázs average 1.8 yards to carry last
year so that why bucking game where he
had seven touchdowns in like eight yards
rushing well Texas Tech probably wore it
was a shootout yeah it was someone
really bad I'll say this see Andre swift
is my 11th overall player so I don't
care that he's our running back taking
him at 26 I'm okay with because like you
said Matt he's got the McCaffrey moulds
where he'll catch 50 passes will run for
a million yards and he could change your
entire offense 27 Seattle Seahawks
you're right
this guy fell pretty far but this is the
great the right landing spot for him
it's AJ epinet yep over here epinet ik
big body player in the moulds of what
Seattle likes he's a very good edge
setter he's a pretty good pass rusher
but he's a raw pass rusher and that's
why in our draft year he falls the 27 I
think the league will like him more than
Matt and I do and he'll go higher than
this but this is the right landing spot
and for a team that could lose Jadeveon
Clowney and free agency and I know they
use draft Capital on the edge and LJ
Collier in the first round last season I
did not like that pick I would like this
one a lot more LJ Collier is not good
and I think they know that
and yeah who knows our guy Ron Reed has
been suspended and as a free agent
evanescent gives you a ton of our
scintilla t upfront if you go to this
route number 28 the Baltimore Ravens I
was eyeing this hoping you had forgotten
epinet it's gonna draft him before he
Girt cuz I perfect replacement for Matt
jus daun instead I'm real middle
linebacker CJ Mosley is a jet now I
think they did miss him this year more
than it seemed especially once the
playoffs got here
Kenneth Murray plug and play in this
defense a dude who we've been watching
for two years and he just he gets better
every time you watch him I thought 2019
he was more explosive
he was quicker in his diagnosing of
offenses he played better outside the
hashes I really like Kenneth Murray I
know everybody's like Patrick Queens the
bell the ball right now
Patrick Queens a hell of a linebacker
let's not forget about Kenneth Murray
cuz he's really really good as well yeah
I love Kenneth's Murray I told you I've
been torn
I took Kenneth Murray to the Raiders in
our last mock this week I went Patrick
Queen
I'll probably just flip them back and
forth until we get to the draft so you
don't listen anymore Raiders fans I'm
just kidding please do it pays the bills
29 the Tennessee Titans this is the
first time I've had him here I thought
about going running back but I'm just
gonna wait till we see the Derrick Henry
situation unfold I'm going what c-czar
ruiz from michigan and what i like about
him is that he can be a phenomenal guard
at 6:43 20 the way he moves but we know
he played center at Michigan so you're
taking an interior offensive lineman and
the Titans have a clear identity of that
they want to punch you in the face run
the football down your throat and Ruiz
is the guy you draft if you want to do
that for the long-term future I will
always recommend loading up on offensive
line for teams that have their
quarterbacks throw the ball 7 to 10
times a game yeah and I mean Roger
scaffolds kind of an older dude Nate
Davis did not have a great year I think
right tackle is gonna be very very key
for them because Jack Conklin who was
their best lineman this year it's a free
agent for agents so we got to kind of
wait and see if there's not a right
tackle here that you would draft either
so they fall in a weird spot number 30
the Green Bay Packers
Justin Jefferson I think is tailor-made
for this offense we've talked often
about you have Davante Adams you got a
little is hard let's get another guy on
there Jeff Jefferson could play in the
slot he could play outside you move all
around your formation he's coming out of
a pro-style system he is ready to rock
and roll and he's gonna give you some
big playability that I think the other
two receivers don't we've talked about
maybe tight in here maybe middle
linebacker Jefferson's value at 30 is
incredible to me he so he's this is
another easy pick Oh a no-brainer I
think Packers fans would be jumping with
joy if they got Justin Jefferson this is
usually the time of the draft Matt where
we've gone ylvis' kishan all Gabe Davis
KJ hamlette Donovan people's Jones and
instead they get a much better player
than Justin Jefferson they're 30 or at
least a safer wide receiver which is
what I think this team needs 31 the
49ers welcome to the first round Antoine
Winfield
I don't I want to make this clear I
don't think he'll be a first-round pick
and that's because he got hurt and
back-to-back years in 17 and 18 I don't
think he'll be an elite athlete at all
for his size
the combine but holy [ __ ] is this guy a
football player and the 49ers know a
little bit about this kind of football
player because they just lost in the
Superbowl 2-1 in the honey badger and
that's really what Winfield reminds me
of at five nine probably 200 pounds 195
he can play cover two he could play
single hi once again I've said it before
I've seen him drop down to the slot he
plays in the box some of the best
instincts I have seen of any player in
this class he can blitz he's got great
hands
if Winfield's medically checks out that
is a big one
medically checks out he is a no-brainer
top 50 player in this class and the
Niners need somebody on the back end
that is a jack-of-all-trades safety
Jimmy Ward's a free agent so he would
fit in perfectly ISO I might note
someone field I pulled him up I mean I I
compared I said honey badger quandary
digs like just an exceptional football
player you're right the injury history
is huge for him though and that's the
difference for me I haven't ranked as
like a fringe one to but injury history
could bottom that out completely so I
think he is a really intriguing guy as a
Niners fan if he's healthy please sign
me up for that all day even in that
defense over a great Delpit over Kyle
Duggar I think he fits more what they
would need number 32 the Kansas City
Chiefs
I would love to trade this pick but like
you said we're not doing that yet corner
is the biggest need for them and unless
they go get a Chris Harris or Darius
slay it will be headed into the
offseason
where you have two guys under contract
your various Ward Rashad fitting Jalen
Johnson's gonna give you some size he's
gonna give you some physicality we're a
talk sack Moss his running back about
this but that defense wasn't made
amazing and I think things at times we
looked at other players like Julian
Blackmun Bradley and I when I got done
with my tape study if you told Johnson
was my favorite prospect from that
program which is gonna have a lot of
dudes drafted so jaylen Johnson here
maybe a tiny bit of a reach but such a
great need for the Chiefs that would
with Gladney gone and off the board
it's like jaylen Johnson AJ Terrell
Christian Fulton and yeah I have Johnson
over Fulton now by the way I don't know
if I've mentioned that on the podcast no
I haven't heard that from you yet phones
injuries bother me and I think I
Texas to an area scale I said if I could
combine greedy Williams and Christian
Fulton I would have a corner that I
really like because I like Fulton the
person characters great leader he's
tough the play really dropped off for me
especially late this year I know he was
battling some injury with the ankle but
that in itself is an issue for me and I
think Fulton is gonna struggle a little
bit to run a man coverage so if he was
gonna go to his own team
he's probably be okay but I think Jalen
Johnson gives you a little bit more
juice and man coverage and he's a little
bit better at the line of scrimmage as
well I think this scheme fit point you
bring up is a really important one that
gets lost a lot in times when we do
these mock drafts and not even just us
but in general of how vital it is you
might have a player that you think is
five to six spots higher on the board as
a talent but if he doesn't fit your
scheme how valuable is he to your
program and for Jalen Johnson the value
for him will be so high because of his
length because of the style he plays he
I mean no one is Jeff Okuda but if
you're looking in the moulds of a player
that has the kind of length that's more
of the bargain version in you know early
round two like you said here Matt may be
a little bit of a reach but early rounds
to kind of range Jalen Johnson is gonna
have a lot of fans in the NFL absolutely
is and as we're closing the show we're
recording Tuesday morning drew Brees
just announced he's coming back for 2020
so oh.sorry Taysom Hill right those
Saints offseason plan is gonna be really
really interesting we are excited to be
joined by one of the best running backs
in the 2020 draft class mr. Zach Moss
from the Utah Utes Zach Congrats on an
amazing career not just a great 2019
season but coming back off the knee
injury you had a dominant year this year
17 touchdowns dude thanks for coming on
with us Thank You Zach net you have the
highest broken tackle rate in this
running back class / PFF and we'd hear
all these names whether it's Jonathan
Taylor DeAndre swift but that to me is
one of the most impressive stats that
we've seen as we go through this draft
class love your running style is there
anyone that you model your game after
you know I grew up watching
Marshawn Lynch you know Bo Jackson you
know those tough gritty running guys
that you know didn't like to go down at
first contact so you know those are the
guys that you know I just you know got
used to watching so much and kind of
just implement into my game
Zach one thing that we're seeing a lot
of NFL teams really focus on more with
the running back position is being able
to catch the ball out of the backfield
and that's something you did really well
in 2017 your sophomore season and this
past year your senior year obviously
that junior you got cut short a little
bit by injury but is that something as
you start to go through this process
where you're you're trying to explain to
teams like hey I could catch the ball
and you're gonna be able to have a
chance in about a week in Indianapolis
to show that off yeah you know kissing
the ball throws and you know pretty
natural for me you know you know I grew
up playing on 707 league you know being
a running back it only went today
catching the ball so you know there's
always been pretty naturally me so like
I said yeah I know Dawson says allow me
to know have some pretty good receiving
receptions and receiving yards in my
years that you talk I know you had the
2018 season cut short and then you come
back this year and your pac-12 Offensive
Player of the Year first-team
all-conference just what was that rehab
like and and that adversity you know
making that kind of come back and
finishing off your college career with
that kind of season you know I couldn't
have scripted it any better you know I
didn't know what to expect coming in you
know coming up with knee injury being my
first significant injury of my career
you know but you know I just continue to
work each and every day you know the
knee injury and the rehab for it was so
it was so long it felt you know a him it
was so gruesome
just going through that you know just
rehab and just you know not being able
to move and things like that but you
know I just kept my head down I kept
working and you know things paid off in
a way that I couldn't even imagine at
the beginning of a year
Zac we were just at the the Senior Bowl
well I guess
it's been a little bit now but one thing
that surprised us a little bit was that
you opted not to you were invited so
you're one of the top players in the
class without a doubt but you opted not
to participate in the Senior Bowl this
year what I'll went into that decision
for you um you know there's me and my
team decided everyone to you know coming
up with very long season I just wanted
to make sure that we were you know and
just maximizing all of our time training
getting ready for this combine its
upcoming a week you know that's why I
thought this was you know the sample is
a great game and things like that you
know but just coming off a long season
you know I played in our scene and I
bowled game which was very late in the
year so just wanted to make sure we were
ready to go for this time by really
what's your day-to-day like right now as
you get ready for the combine in a
couple weeks here you know took over the
last month it has been every single day
Monday through Saturday about nine to
three just you know in the weight rooms
in the you know rehab facility and on
the fields in the second half of the day
so you know it's it's a non-stop go you
know it's it's a grind over here for
sure a lot of guys go into this and
they're focused on you know adding
weight cutting weight or you know you're
hyper focused on your 40 has it been
that way for you where you know you're
working with your trainers to really
hone in on one thing or is it just about
overall balance to your you know your
health your the drills you're gonna do
and everything that goes into that um
you know for me it is one thing yes you
know my 40 is gonna be the biggest thing
for me you know that's one thing that
I've been harping on the most you know
just trying to make sure that I'm ready
to go for that but you know we've
definitely just been fine swimming
everything that we've been doing off
drills know on the board you know
learning on to the meetings and things
like that so it's definitely been oh do
it hitting everything but you know for
me has definitely been just 240 it's
been my main focus one
thing we were a little surprised about
on this show was that your teammate
Tyler Huntley did not get a compound
invite
we felt like he had obviously a great
season you guys had an incredible
offense and defense do you think he
could play quarterback at the next level
and just what was it like playing with
him this last couple of years
oh you know I mean kind of Nestle the
last five years together going back into
our senior in high school Wow
and it was you know honestly the best
play with my career
Echo's you know it's been fun being able
to play with a guy that called so much
havoc for decent you know and it makes
my life a lot easier has a running back
we have another two someone back there
but you that can also run the ball so it
keeps defense off off ads and things
like that but um Lehigh was definitely
surprising that he didn't get a combine
and by you know no matter if he I
believe he can play quarterback at the
next level no matter if he can play an i
it was surprising that he didn't get a
combine invite because of the numbers
that he had this year the Heisman hype
that he was getting you know you had
yeah all the numbers up there just with
Jill Burrell and the rest of those guys
so it was kind of surprising that he
really didn't get one this year when you
see him it's like you said I mean you've
known this guy forever you have a great
look I don't have much NFL you watch but
was there ever time your watch to Tyler
and you're like this is Lamar Jackson
that I'm lining up behind me just some
of the plays that he makes this year and
even the body style that it's easy to
see a little bit of Lamar in his game
yeah you know and he had him and Lamar
actually played against each other in
high school I think lost it twice but he
definitely has that athletic build
similar to Lamar I think Lamar a bit
more you know compact and you know a
little bit more beefier and things like
that
but you know just the way he runs and
they really miss effort he has is
definitely similar similar to Lamar but
he definitely have some good traits
speaking of high school what was it like
going from Florida to Utah
um it was you know only a culture shock
cold right yeah yeah I was definitely it
was definitely cold no doubt but you
know it was it was exactly what I needed
you know it was um it was good for me
you know to go out there and you know
learn a mature by myself you know see
things see different part of life that
is you know totally the opposite of what
I was accustomed to you know I'm getting
out of my comfort zone you know I just
playing football in a different part of
the world was just lovely you know in
the last four years
hey you told was really good to me Zach
would you have ever thought because you
were originally committed to play at the
University of Miami four years ago would
you have ever thought that Utah would be
unquestionably a better program than to
you mmm no I I can't say that you know
just know just from the talent level
that did the University of Miami brings
in each and every year you know net
coming goes you know they still have a
lot of talent and they get a lot of guys
and a lot of the topic troops and things
like that you know I just don't believe
they found the right coaching yet in
that whole system and how that thing is
gonna play out but you know you know
Utah's had the same head coach for a
while close close Winningham and things
like that I think staff around you know
and they're trending up and getting
talent you know as we had a lot of good
seasons over the past years you know
guys trying to notice and you know want
to take leaps out to you talking about
where you're from so you know I think
it's one gun looking to get better for
them we talked a lot about how explosive
the offense was with you obviously
Tyler Huntley but what was it like
practicing against that defense every
day I mean every single time we look at
this defense just feels like more and
more guys come out of there that are
gonna get drafted especially this year
where we're expecting at least five of
them to get drafted how much did that
prepare you each week I mean it was
lovely
you know you
and definitely over the years always
there we've always had you know and
that's what just in the pack at least
the top three defense each and every
year but this year was you know I'm
totally different it was we probably has
the best defense and every category they
were definitely top three around the
nation so you know we had to go against
that defense and you know it was
definitely getting us better each and
every week you know and I think that was
a good reason why we had the season that
we had you know those guys kept us on
our toes and we definitely you know try
to do our best to keep them you know as
sharp as they possibly could and and
there's so much talent out there it is
crazy was the hardest hit you took in
your four years of Utah was it in
practice for senator game because I
imagine just not even discussed earlier
this year but what you've seen during
your time there Utah I mean there's been
some amazing defensive players um
my heart is hit you know they kept me
away from getting here some guys I'm
good yeah get me away from getting here
too much in practice from those guys but
you know my heart from Arizona State
this year I'm in this past year my
senior we played them at home you know
and I got a hit directly to the head
targeting hit I'm kind of like a
blindside Zac well thank you so much man
we're excited to watch it the combine
and rooting for you this year in the
draft and we just want to wish you the
best of luck going forward
Thank You Man appreciate it very much
thank you all right